a new type of coronavirus has emerged
from the city of Wuhan in China
within weeks it has spread to several
countries and has killed multiple people
Korona refers to the virus's distinctive
shape they are a large group common
among mammals and birds but in rare
cases like this one they can spread to
humans a process known as zoonosis this
new virus is the seventh known human
corona virus and it affects the
respiratory system some corona viruses
have mild symptoms however others and
much more dangerous SARS and MERS are
both corona viruses the most urgent
question is how does it spread it seems
the virus can be transmitted between
humans but it's still unclear whether
this happens routinely some early severe
cases caused a lot of concern but this
has receded slightly as more mild cases
turn up the new virus does not seem to
be as deadly as SARS which killed around
11% of the people infected researchers
think that the virus originated in an
unknown animal at market in Wuhan
identifying that animal could help
control the current outbreak and gage is
frakked going forward
the viruses genetic code could offer
clues to its origins and spread labs in
China and Thailand have sequenced at
least 19 strains from infected people
and made them publicly available
analysis is ongoing there are no known
drugs that can effectively treat corona
virus infections in humans and no
vaccines are currently licensed but
researchers are working on the problem
one possible Avenue is to block the
receptor the virus is used to infect
humans with more cases being reported
every day the race is on to contain the
outbreak and scientists are at the heart
of the effort